[Music]
my new book 10 years in the making is
called forged in crisis the power of
courageous leadership in turbulent times
and it's it's spotlights 5 astounding
now really legendary leaders who found
themselves each in the midst of a great
crisis and how in the midst of that
crisis they made themselves capable of
doing impossible things so it's really a
book about how ordinary people can make
themselves capable of doing
extraordinary things each of the five
people in this book that in Antarctic
Explorer Ernest Shackleton American
President Abraham Lincoln the escaped
slave and abolitionist Frederick
Douglass the Nazi resisting minister
lutheran minister Dietrich Bonhoeffer
and the environmental activist and
Crusader Rachel Carson discover that
resilience is absolutely critical to
accomplishing their mission and we like
to think or many of us like to think I
certainly thought this before I really
got to know these people that resilience
was something I was born with I had a
slow a healthy slog of it
I would access and use it and then that
would serve me well when I needed it
even though I couldn't be exactly sure
when that would be but I don't think
that's the that's the case these stories
teach us that each of these people
worked on their own resilience they
discover some in themselves Shackleton
finds his ship trapped in the ice right
drifting hopelessly like a like a board
stuck in a vise along the currents off
the coast of Antarctica and early 1915
he's he's powerless to do anything about
it after lots and lots of trying he
can't pry the ship loose and so somehow
he's got to find it himself anyway we
can read about his efforts to do this in
the diary the reserves he needs he says
I pray to God I can shape my mark to a
new mark now that the old goal now that
the old mark has run aground his old
goal of crossing the Antarctic is now
over so he's got to shape himself to the
to the mark of saving his man and he's
like pray God I can do that than myself
and what and so he starts off with I'm
gonna try and do this I've got to have
that covenant with myself to get better
and stronger in this moment and then
interestingly and this is true
throughout these stories in different
contexts different times a moment arises
that demands more resilience you know he
a mutiny is threatened by his men and he
knows from Antarctic history that mutiny
and despair and discord and alienation
among the man on a particular expedition
can kill an expedition just as quickly
just as surely as running out of food or
cold temperatures or scurvy and so a
mutiny a mutiny threatens to erupt and
Shackleton has to in a sense move in to
the fear take one step into the fear of
dealing with the head mutineer hold it
together and then stay resilient enough
to get through that moment and then to
learn from it so he can do all kinds of
proactive things to prevent mutiny from
rising up and threatening the expedition
again so one of the interesting things
that all five of these people learn as
they develop what I would call and I'm
not the first person to use this term
the muscles of resilience right the
muscles of endurance ones stores of grit
one of the things he's discovers is that
the way you can access that and then
make it stronger is actually in the
moment of a crisis in the moment of
sudden confusion or volatility to take
the first step into the anxiety in the
fear that all of us including the leader
have within themselves it doesn't have
to be a big step you're not no you're
not leaving a building at all bound you
don't have a superhuman cape or a wand
or Gandalf's magic from Lord of the
Rings you do have the ability to step
one small step into that and and
literally confront in the case of
Shackleton confront his carpenter chippy
mcNeish who was threatening to mutiny
and figure out in that moment in that
moment that encounter that confrontation
how to quell how to both both quell his
the the mutineers protests and anger and
at the same time cordon him off so that
he cannot spread the contagion
of mutiny immediately among other team
members so it's in the the first step of
honing and strengthening our resilience
muscles is to take the first step into
the fear into the unknown into the
uncertainty and it's just a small step
and the wonderful thing about charting
the stories as I do a chart them you
know it's the growth this is the making
over time of leaders is you learn that
each of these people from Frederick
Douglas to Dietrich Bonhoeffer to
Abraham Lincoln get more resilient and a
little bit quicker about stepping into
the fear and a little more brave about
stepping you the fear with each step
that they take so you take the step
shackled and took the step with the
mutiny ships carpenter and then four
months later when another moment arises
that's really frightening and the men
again are really worried and threatening
to peel off in the pockets of fear he
has actually more quicker access to his
resilience because he knows he got
through one moment of it before that and
on and on and on and so it's a creative
it's about the mileage of moving into
our fear just with a tiny step
tightening our core squaring our
shoulders moving into it and then
getting more access to our inner
strength getting more access to our
resilience so resilience is absolutely
critical and yet I am tale I am
absolutely certain that it doesn't come
from on high we can't download it on our
iPhones but we can devout discover it
within ourselves and develop it within
ourselves and find it stronger and
easier to get each time as we move
forward
[Music]